you should teach them ching chang chong
I would like to learn some GTA challenge
I'll teach you right now give me
something beads you know what that means
Pizza yeah
your eyebrows
dude that's really good come on buddy
dude your pronouncing is good dude
because I'm mimicking with your whole
like Bingo
and I used to work at a Korean
restaurant so you get something I hit on
one of the wages and they got all like
ready to bridge yeah then I'm ready to
mix we're trying to be the master race
it's always funny coming from a Japanese
one they did a good job almost being a
masterpie yeah Japanese like to me
they're like meat this is a reason
there's these
I take it easy Japanese lady